thailand knows a thing or two about
fighting for its democracy
these former thai air force members are
now political activists known for
leading protests in 2020 against the
military-backed government
now they see a need for their services
in ukraine
i have been involved in demanding
democracy in my country and opposing
tyranny ukrainians are also fighting for
democracy and are now invaded by a
superpower and a tyrant so i asked
myself what i could do for them this is
the reason why i applied
china pongpai has started recruiting
others to join him in just one day he
says he received two thousand names of
people interested in volunteering
we fight for democracy here they fight
for their democracy there we are like
friends it's the same feeling the same
ideology
to me it's unfair to the ukrainian
people because the attack happened not
only at a military base but also at
hospitals kindergarten schools and
civilian areas this is the reason why i
want to go help them if you ask me
whether i'm scared to get killed of
course i'm scared
the ukrainian embassy in bangkok is
tasked with vetting the recruits they
need to provide proof of military
training and have a clean criminal
record
pong pai said his training from two
years in the air force could help the
ukrainians protect civilians guard areas
and secure supply lines
i want to tell ukrainians that you are
not fighting alone
many people want to help you don't lose
hope and feel that the world has
abandoned you even if we are not a
superpower even if we are only a small
light we can shine a bright light to
help you if we all join together
please wait we are in the process of
coming to help you
thailand was among 141 countries at the
united nations general assembly that
voted to reprimand russia for invading
ukraine and demand moscow stop fighting
and withdraw its military forces
while it's not clear if pongpai or his
friends will be accepted to help ukraine
they've already begun to prepare
offering help from an unlikely corner of
the world
leah harding al jazeera